Leena starts us off this hour in New
York City Eileen oh welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hi thank you thank you for
taking my call
sure what's up in your world well I'm
currently Dave right now I have a lot of
student loans and I have some credit
card debt that I'm trying to you know
pay off but just the amount of income
that I have that comes into a month it's
not really able to them like you don't
even touch or pay off the student loans
but I'm able to pay off the credit cards
but it'll just take a few months for
that that happens yeah so I'm a single
mom I have I have a six-year-old son and
most of the student loans that came came
from when I was in pharmacy school did
you complete pharmacy school I didn't
continue because like it just happened
last year I had gotten I had gotten
dismissed from the program because I had
a serious family emergency that kind of
jeopardized my seeding and I had to
withdraw my application and be kicked
out of the program so how long were you
in how long were you in pharmacy school
for five for four years you were in for
four years four years yeah what did you
like right how much did you like
graduating I only had three courses left
in completing the on campus on the
coursework and then I had to do one year
of rotations and then after one year you
graduate and you have to take your
boards and become a pharmacist yeah what
level of family emergency would keep you
from going across that finish line well
I have a parent that has like on
uncontrolled high blood pressure and
diabetes and they suffered a stroke you
know very close to stroke and that kind
of um had to take on some serious care
and
in terms of helping them and that kind
of like you don't mess with the time
that I had to send for for my my home
studies mmm it was wrong and what who's
taking care of the parent now
well so far like you know the parent is
they're still with me and I'm still
helping them out and you know not being
an in pharmacy anymore I'm doing courses
online and I I'm doing I'm doing health
care management now online and I'm going
to be graduating from there next year
next year spring semester so it's just
that like since I have all that said
just trying to figure out like what
should be like and so on all they all
the student loan that's on hold right
now cuz you're back in school yeah how
much student loan debt do you have
almost 80,000 that's including credit
cards as well and how much of that's
credit cards and credit cards itself I
didn't add it up about seven thousand
you're almost done with that you said
what is your income income is a thousand
per month you're living on twelve
thousand dollars a year in New York City
you got your parents income to or
something yeah my mom you know like
that's the trend I'm with um she's
retired so she's um you know like she
has her pension Social Security that's
thing like all of the arms the mortgage
and everything else all the bills and
then I'm just I'm sharing with my son
I'd say for my son from my son's tuition
for school and then like I I try to take
care of like you know buying groceries
and paying off credit cards and
everything okay so like what my what my
plan was to do was just to try and see
with um trying to get back into pharmacy
school again and I even tried to sign up
for like a real estate licensing you
know just
just for that to be like a side hustle
but it's like I even thought of like
trying to invest but then like you know
hearing from your chosen yeah you don't
need to invest you need to finish you
need to finish one of these degrees and
get your income up are you even are you
working full-time all right I'm okay why
because you're caring you're caring for
your mother like you know juggling my
son and mom it's it's kind of tough
yeah I can imagine okay I'm sorry honey
you got you got your plate full here's
the thing here's the thing you've got to
figure in order to have a career long
term in either one of these things
health care management or pharmacy
you're going to have to be able to work
full time aren't you yes how are you
going to do that it like you know future
wise but it's like you know I'm kind of
focusing on just trying to finish
there's no reason listen the reason to
finish the degrees is to get your income
up right yeah we're not collecting
degrees you're not a thermometer okay we
we only need degrees to be able to make
our enter to make more money and you
can't make more money unless you're able
or you put your life in a situation
where you can work full-time and that
means that you're going to have to
arrange for other care for your mother
aren't you long term not today but as
you graduate from either one of these
degree fields in order to take advantage
of having that degree you're gonna have
to be able to work am I wrong about that
you know so I don't want you going into
debt any further I don't want you
collecting degrees just to collect
degrees just to say you did I'm
heartbroken that you got this close to
the finish line on that pharmacy degree
and have basically paid for it but
weren't able to finish it I wish you
could get back in line on that at some
point because that's a hundred to a
hundred and fifty thousand dollar your
job and your
life changes dramatically and you've got
the money then to actually hire someone
to care for your mother but actually the
money that she has coming in from
retirement would pay for a caregiver you
know in her situation and you may have
to go that route you may not have
another way around it so you just go
have to look at that and think about
long-term okay five years from today
where am I going and step by step how am
I going to get there the hundred and
eighty thousand dollars doesn't scare me
if you're making 150 a year I want you
to pay it off really fast it's really
bad but it doesn't scare me it does
scare me if you think you're gonna make
twelve thousand a year for the next ten
years and and stay in your mother's home
and care for her that's not a plan
you're gonna have to do something else
you box yourself in the corner here
short-term you took care of your mom
that's there's this a wonderful thing
you did long term you're going to take
care of your son which involves
arranging other care for your mother I
think unless I'm missing something I'm
not trying to be mean to your mom or
something I just try to think about how
you're gonna take care of your kid and
your $180,000 mess Wow
you call me back if I can help I'll help
you any way I can kiddo this is the Dave
Ramsey show